un trailer pokémon vient de sortir et
plein de nouveautés ont été annoncées
l'évolution des starters les combats
wifi bref une information inédite a été
énoncée dans le trailer une démo de
pokémon soleil et lune sera disponible
le 18 octobre tout comme ruby oméga et
saphir alpha à l'époque
cependant ce n'est pas ce qui nous
intéresse dans la démo imminente de
sonner moon nous contrôlerons sacha nobi
l'amphi nobi de sacha qui aura le talent
synergies et oui ça fait un moment que
je rabâche ce mot et ils sont enfin d'un
trailer pokémon ce talon permettra en
fine au biel se transformer durant le
combat comme une méga évolution s'il
parvient à tuer l'un des pokémon de
l'adversaire mais le plus intéressant
est que comme la version démo de rosa il
sera possible de transférer nos pokémon
jouer vers la version intégrale c'est à
dire que nous pourrons transférer cet
amphi nobi spécial vers des jeux
officiel de pokémon sonne et moon étant
un chasseur de chagny l'idée de posséder
cet amphi noblian shiny serait
invraisemblablement incroyable et bien
ce serait possible la théorie commence
ici on pourrait penser qu étant donné
que ce pokémon est spéciale et qu'il
provient d'une démo il serait impossible
de faire certaines choses avec je parle
surtout de le reproduire
et c'est en finn hobby est tout à fait
normal il a juste un talent incroyable
qui ait cnrj et ce n'est pas un talent
caché
contrairement au pitch ou trois épis de
heart gold et soul silver qui possédait
une forme différente
par exemple il est évident qu'il ne peut
pas reproduire sa forme car il est
unique mais le passant finaux be
d'ailleurs ce pokémon à la possibilité
de se reproduire et nombreux sont ceux
qui l'ont cherchée en shiny comment
pourrait-on posséder ce fabuleux ninja
en chromatique
il est évident qu'il sera shine ilog
lors de la démo nintendo depuis xy de
verrouiller les pokémon important de la
version pour ne pas les avoir en chagny
sol galeo et luna à la le seront très
certainement mais l'argument clé surtout
que ce ne sera qu'une démo pas une
version officielle donc il ne sera pas
possible de leur visite est toutefois
une méthode dévoilée par junichi masuda
le créateur de nombreux jeux pokémon
avait dévoilé un moyen d'avoir des
pokémon szczesny via la pension cette
méthode s'appelle la méthode massouda
d'où son nom
elle consiste à coupler deux pokémon
d'origine différente c'est à dire deux
pokémon provenant de pays différents par
exemple un métamorphe japonais et
qu un amphi nobi français vous voyez où
je veux en venir enfin pour garder le
talent synergies il faudra se baser sur
la chance nous ne savons pas si le
talent synergie sera un talent
dreamworld mais il pourra certainement
se transmettre si lyon finovi possède en
synergie est un mal et qu'ils
s'accouplent avec un métamorphe avec en
plus une chance sur 512
si vous possédez le charme khroma de
devenir shiny je ferai cette méthode
soyez en sûr et j'espère vraiment que
nous pourrons le chasser merci de
m'avoir écouté vivement la sortie de sun
et moon et vive le lay gunners s'étaient
argot rock